HORSE OF A DIFFERENT COLOR.
>> Sandra: WE EXPECT NEWS TO
REPORT ON THAT THROUGHOUT THE
DAY.
THANK YOU.
>> Ed: ANOTHER FOX NEWS REPORT
ON CAPITOL HILL.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI WILL TESTIFY
REMOTELY BEFORE THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE ALONG WITH
THREE OTHER KEY MEMBERS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE.
ACCORDING TO EARLY REPORTS,
PRESIDENT THOUGHT SHE PLANS TO
REOPENING.
THE SENATE MINORITY LEADER
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER’S URGING
FALLACY NOT TO HOLD BACK.
>> THIS WILL BE ONE OF THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DR. FAUCI TO
TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
UNVARNISHED TRUTH WITHOUT THE
PRESIDENT LOOKING OVER HIS
SHOULDER.
DR. FAUCI, LET IT RIP.
>> Ed: BRET BAIER AND
DANA PERINO AND ALL OF OUR TOP
DOCTORS WILL JOIN US.
GOOD MORNING TED.
>> GOOD MORNING ED.
THIS IS THE FIRST BIG HEARING ON
CORONAVIRUS.
AND AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
DIFFERENT STATES ARE JUMPING THE
GUN.
YOU’RE SOMETHING THOUGHT SHE
WILL TESTIFY TO THIS MORNING.
THIS WILL NOT ONLY RESULT IN
NEEDLESS SUFFERING AND DEATH BUT
WILL ACTUALLY SET US BACK IN OUR
QUEST TO RETURN TO NORMAL.
HERE IS SENATE MINORITY LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER.
>> UNTIL NOW WE MOSTLY HEARD
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE THROUGH
THE DISTORTED LEARNINGS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE CONFERENCE.
THE WHITE HOUSE OFTEN PREVENTS
HIM FROM ANSWERING FULLY,
INTERRUPTS THEIR RESPONSE OR
EVEN CONTRADICTS THEIR
FACT-BASED ADVICE.
>> THIS HEARING WILL LOOK
DIFFERENT THAN MOST AND ALL THE
WITNESSES WILL TESTIFY REMOTELY.
DR. FAUCI ANOTHER HAD POTENTIAL
EXPOSURE TO CORONAVIRUS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, AN AIDE CONTRACTED
CORONAVIRUS SO HE’S IN
SELF-ISOLATION FOR TWO WEEKS.
THE TOP DEMOCRAT ON THE PANEL
WASHINGTON SENATOR PATTY MURRAY
HAS BEEN WORKING FROM HOME AFTER
THE BIGGER NURSING HOME OUTBREAK
IN HER STATE.
LAST WEEK ALEXANDER SAID
LAWMAKERS BACK AND FORTH TO
WASHINGTON, THE SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL FOCUS
ON ANOTHER LAWSUIT.
>> THIS WILL BE ABOUT THE WOT
TIME IN LIVING MEMORY TO LET
TRIAL LAWYERS LINED THEIR
POCKETS AT THEIR EXPENSE OF THE
REST OF OUR COUNTRY.
THE SENATE WILL PLAY A STRONG
ROLE IN ENSURING THAT WHAT DOES
NOT HAPPEN.
>> ALSO HEARS SOMETHING TO LOOK
FOR.
LET’S TALK ABOUT HOW THIS
HEARING IS GOING TO LOOK
DIFFERENT THAN MOST OF THE
HEARINGS OF MOST OF THE SENATORS
BEING IN REMOTELY.
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE STEPS THAT
NEED TO BE TAKEN TO REOPEN THE